Please welcome vice president global advanced
manufacturing at Lear, Jennifer Johnson. [Music]
All right, good morning. My name is Jennifer
Johnson and I am here to share a glimpse into
the journey of Palanteer Foundry at Lear
Corporation. Lear is a global leader in
automotive seating and e systems. Our team of
more than 173,000 employees across 37 countries
designs, manufactures, and delivers advanced
technologies to the world's leading automakers.
With over 100 years of heritage, Lear is
the largest US-based automotive supplier,
proudly headquartered in Michigan. Guided by our
commitment to innovation, operational excellence,
and sustainability, Lear's global team
is shaping the future of mobility with
solutions that enhance comfort, safety, and
efficiency. The automotive industry dynamics
and resulting operational complexities are
endless. To assist our team in navigating
through the realities of today's marketplace,
we are working to support our employees and our
customers through our Palanteer Foundry
platform. And we haven't looked back.
Never underestimate the ability of a small group
of dedicated people to change the world. Isn't
that how the saying goes? And a couple of years
ago at Lear, it was exactly that. a small group
of dedicated people who built our first use case
with Palunteer. It's easy for me to stand here
and summarize the road that we've traveled since
that initial use case. And depending on where you
are in your journey with Foundry, you already know
it's no joke. It's not an out-of-the-box solution.
It's not a flip the switch project. Value through
Foundry is extracted through a deep relationship
with the Palunteer team and a long-term investment
of time and resources from within an organization.
So back to that initial use case, it built the
foundation of manufacturing production support
at Lear. And from that initial use case, we built
more involving our manufacturing execution system
integration and further monitoring applications.
Next, we built into our supply chain and that
positions us to our current ambition, dynamic
decision-making in support of just in time seat
assembly. So, let's turn our attention to JIT
operations to understand more about what I'm
referring to for automakers to offer a broad range
of options for customers like you and me. Their
models are designed to accommodate thousands
of end item vehicle versions. So, as a tier
one supplier, Lear's processes must be optimized
to meet very tight requirements. So, I'm talking
about product complexity delivered just in time
with the highest quality and of course the lowest
cost. Lear only has a 4-hour broadcast window from
the time a fixed customer order is placed to the
time a seat must be present at the seat install
point within an automaker's assembly plant.
There are on average 350 unique part numbers that
are picked and staged that are components within
a seat. After assembly, seed is all seats are
inspected and tested for fit and function. They
are then readied for a sequenced delivery
to our customer assembly plant. The point
I'm trying to make here is that a just in time
seat operation is a very intense environment.
We're shipping seeds at 60 jobs an hour, 24 hours
a day, 5 days a week. Considering Lear's global
scale of over 175 just in time plants, thousands
of decisions are made daily to po to both secure
ontime delivery and also optimize our processes.
So, sounds like a great opportunity for an AIP
powered Foundry application, don't you think?
Well, we thought so. So, let's take a closer look
and join the team in Flint, Michigan to see what's
going on today. Welcome to the JIT control tower,
where operations teams start their day. The
control tower is a real time bird's eye view
of Lear's operation. On the left, we see the
production line status. It's a continuous influx
of orders and deliveries. And on the map we see
a highle routing of incoming material from tier
2 suppliers located across North America. These
are components and subsystems and route from
other leer sites or other thirdparty suppliers.
So how do we do it? How do we orchestrate the
convergence of a continuous flow of customer
customer demand with the right material and the
right resources on hand exactly at the right time.
We do this through dynamic production scheduling.
To optimize production scheduling, we combine
the expertise of our operations team and our
engineering team with Foundar's AIP horsepower. In
this view, we're experiencing the conbound board.
This is a pipeline of activities and actions that
together execute to a schedule that our teams
monitor. During a shift, dynamic line scheduling
is informed through the integration of multiple
applications. If you remember those use cases I
mentioned earlier, these applications reconcile
things like inbound material availability,
real time production throughput, and finished
good inventory capacity. At the most left is our
exceptions board and our planners spend their time
there interfacing, triaging and closing concerns
in material availability or production alerts,
anything that may impact our most time-sensitive
deliveries. And our teams are trained to react
to exceptions. At times, our customer demand
is within that 4hour window that they set.
This means customers are asking us to break
that schedule that we planned and expedite
what we all call a hot job. AIP alerts us now
of a hot job and our ops team engages to assess
the best alternatives within the schedule
to deliver. Planners run the AI agent, our
scheduling agent and its power to assess our bill
of materials and standard labor content involved.
The scheduling agent offers options to allocate
the job during the shift. The resulting impact
to the schedule and inventories on hand is
considered. So I point out a hot job as an
example. It's a perfect example of how AIP and
the Lear turn team up on the production floor.
Foundry delivers the decision layer while
the plant operations team brings practical
product and supply chain and manufacturing
know-how. Engineering assesses complexity
through simulation while foundry ingests inputs,
finds the best slot, and makes a proposal. Last,
operations reviews the plan, considers the next
best alternative, and approves or escalates if
needed. When ready, the job is placed and written
back to Lear's MEES system. As we build the JIT
control tower and new AI agents, we have our
global manufacturing team in mind. We just
reviewed one line and one plant. Multiply that by
hundreds of plants and as many operations teams
making those thousands and thousands of decisions
daily. I find the most rewarding part of deploying
Foundry applications are the aha moments. And
we all have them. It's the moment a production
planner realizes he no longer must spend hours
each day pouring over Excel spreadsheets and on
conference calls reconciling and onhand inventory
with his uh Mexican counterparts. And it's the
moment the plant manager realizes she now has
a digital assistant supporting her ability to
execute more effectively in her 24-hour a day,
5day a week operating rhythm. In conclusion,
Foundry allows us to focus on what matters,
keeping our plants running smoothly and delivering
the highest quality product to our customer. And
many thanks to the Palunteer team for supporting
us along the way as we solve for our greatest
opportunities. Thank you so much. [Music]